all right this is kind of blunt but
difference between a narcissist on
social media versus someone that's just
a really great promoter of themselves
it's can an artist do it wrong yeah
absolutely and there's a huge difference
a person who promotes himself really
really well still takes the world view
of engaging other people a narcissist on
social media is strictly a broadcaster
it's somebody that is out there
consistently broadcasting the same
message the the most consistent or the
the best example I can give of that is
it happens all the time on Twitter
people go and they see a you know a
follower count you know we have like 128
thousand followers on Twitter they see
that number and immediately say support
my campaign and then when you go to
their or take a look at my video hey
look at my reel and they don't even take
the time that the amazing thing is is
Hey look at my reel but then you look up
that person's name on stage 32 and then
not on the site not even a member so
they haven't even taken the time to read
your profile to see what you do okay Oh
to ask you a question about it
they just see that number and they say
okay I'm gonna go after them and then if
you go to their profile on Twitter
you'll see that they're posting the same
message static to everybody right and if
you go and you look at the number of
followers of each person that they're
hitting 250 thousand it's 60 thousand so
what these people have done is taken the
time to do the research into who has a
lot of followers so that they can bless
them with narcissistic you know behavior
like you know look at my real look man
now a crowdfunding I mean sometimes it's
just complete lack of education but that
is a problem to me as well because that
means you're lazy because most most
crowdfunding platform first of all 7,000
articles out there about crowdfunding I
wrote one about you know crowdfunding on
Twitter or you know promoting a
crowdfunding campaign on Twitter and the
mistakes you make but the major
crowdfunding platforms out there not
only have live people assisting you but
they give you kits on how to do it so if
you have made the choice to ignore those
or not read those and it's not worth
your time it's not my worth my time to
even look at what you're doing you know
I mean you're obviously you just want
you just think
you're a genius and you know if you
build it they will come and you know how
could it possibly fail what I'm just
gonna blast everybody with my you know
my genius that's the met that's at least
what you're putting forth to me sure
and I know crowdfunding is a different
animal and people tend to there's almost
a crowdfunding psychosis that sets in I
you know understandably you know time is
on the line but let's talk about maybe
someone that's not under the pressure of
their campaign expiring the difference
between narcissistic behavior of an
actor or a filmmaker screenwriter or
whatever versus an artist that just is
really doing it right yeah I mean it's
the same thing it's the look-at-me
behavior it's look at my look at my reel
look at my reel look at my reel I just
hey I just cut my hey I just got my reel
yo you know take a look at this it's
like you know first of all the approach
is terrible second of all I mean another
thing that's just a huge turnoff for
example like the narcissistic behavior
is hey hey hey and you're doing it to
people you're not even following on
social media or you're doing it to
people that you don't know anything
about on social media a good perform a
good promoter would be somebody that has
already engaged you in some way and say
would say to me hey RB you know this is
my new acting reel would you mind taking
a look at it now that's a totally
different thing if that person is
already following me not let me using
the Twitter example if that person is
ready following me on Twitter okay
that's okay that's cool he's taking the
time to follow me he's following what
I'm doing if it's if he's engaged me
over and over again I think that's
fantastic as well okay and that is the
give-and-take okay
now I'm much more compelled to maybe go
take a look at okay I much rather than
do that for stage 32 of course that's
supposed to get on you know they're not
and I would like to see that like I will
go to that person's profile and I will
say how come you haven't uploaded it yet
you know I mean I'll ask that question
because again it's closing the circle
right so I try to in those types of
situations when you're a good promoter
and you've engaged me
and you've done all those things right
you've shown me that you're not just a
broadcaster and you're not just being a
narcissist but when I'm compelled to do
now is not only look at your reel but
maybe help you by saying why aren't you
posting it here why haven't you put this
link here like you're not I mean this is
gonna get you more followers more likes
more comments why don't you do this you
know more people are going to see it so
it's all about engagement it's all about
that's the difference
you